[Música]
a
es historia republicana pero lleva a
cuatro presidentes destituidos por el
congreso este país está marcado por la
injerencia de legislativo en el orden
democrático era en 1823 y josé de la
riva-agüero primer presidente de esta
nación fue despojado de su cargo por el
parlamento tiempo después en 1914
guillermo billinghurst no pudo contener
la ofensiva de sus opositores en el
congreso y éstos le aplicaron la
vacancia presidencial por incapacidad
moral en este siglo el legislativo
destituido alberto fujimori el año 2000
tras descubrirse la corrupción en su
gobierno el parlamento lo depuso
alegando permanente incapacidad moral y
en este escalafón la víctima más
reciente es martín vizcarra fue acusado
de haber recibido sobornos sin ninguna
investigación y solo en base a denuncias
el congreso lo sacó de la presidencia
por incapacidad moral diversos sectores
consideran que el congreso de perú
ejerce supremacía sobre los gobiernos y
se aprovecha de una vaga cláusula
constitucional para destituir
presidentes cuando lo considera
conveniente
[Música]
en eeuu el congreso puede destituir al
presidente al vicepresidente a jueces y
oficiales del servicio civil la cámara
de representantes- es la única que puede
acusar o abrir un proceso de destitución
sin embargo es el senado que no juzga al
presidente y toma la decisión final se
necesitan dos tercios del senado para
aprobar un proceso de destitución y no
hay posibilidad de apelación el juicio o
impeachment contra un presidente solo se
puede dar por traición por soborno o por
otros altos crímenes y delitos en
febrero de este año trump fue acusado
por la cámara de representantes de altos
crímenes por abuso de poder y tratar de
obstruir el congreso pero fue absuelto
por el senado de mayoría republicana los
otros dos presidentes que han pasado por
impeachment fueron andrew johnson en
1868 y bill clinton en 1999 pero los dos
fueron absueltos
[Música]
desde el final de la dictadura militar
en brasil hubo dos procesos de
impeachment en 1992 el presidente
fernando color de me lo paso por un
proceso de destitución en el congreso
pero presentó sus dimisiones antes de
que el proceso llegase a su fin y pasó a
su cargo el número 2 color había sido
acusado por su propio hermano de
corrupción ya en 2016 le tocó a la
presidenta dilma rousseff justo después
de la celebración de los juegos
olímpicos de río de janeiro rousseff fue
acusada de peralada fiscales es decir de
irregularidades en la gestión de los
presupuestos públicos pero tanto el
partido de los trabajadores como una
parte de la opinión pública siempre
defendieron que se trató de un golpe
blanco para alejar a la izquierda del
poder en esos momentos le toca al
gobernador del estado de río de janeiro
wilson weeks el acusado de desviar
dinero público para combatir la pandemia
del coronavirus
[Música]